[Music]
fire has always
been associated with destruction and
loss of control and what else you might
ask is seen doing the same
well monsters well in this list we shall
showcase the top 10 biggest fire
monsters seen
in the movies one important note to you
all would be
that we won't be including dragons as
they are going to be in another list
so here we have the demons titans kaiju
and other creatures that are constantly
on fire
or in a state of burning like having
their body made up of lava and magma so
before you watch it all
remember to take a look at our teespring
store and we have quite a number of
merch for sale so please support us
and for the subscribers click on that
notification bell for regular updates
so here is the top 10 list of the fire
monsters from movies
number 10 el diablo from suicide squad
chateau santana also known as el diablo
which is spanish for the devil
was a meta human criminal and was
recruited forcefully to be a member of
the task force
x santana was seemingly born with his
pyrokinetic powers which means power to
control flames and fire however in the
past he lost control over them
and accidentally killed his wife and
children in a fiery inferno
which devastated him and led him to
willingly surrender himself to the
police
because of this experience he was
initially reluctant to use his
pyrokinetic powers
out of guilt and fear although he
ultimately sacrificed his life in order
to defeat in cubas
as he unleashed all his powers and he
transformed into a 15 foot tall aztec
fire demon
number nine the balrog from law of the
rings also known as the valor rocker
they were mire that was seduced and
corrupted by melkor
into his service balrogs generally took
the form of tall
menacing beings roughly humanoid in
shape though seemingly to consist
or be surrounded by shadow and flame
they used both a flaming sword and a
fiery whip
and they were constantly burning and the
weapons appeared molten
it is unclear and highly debated if the
bellrocks had
wings although the one that we see in
fellowship of the ring had wings but
barely could fly a single ball rock or
around 20 feet tall or six meters
who we know now as during spain managed
to drive the dwarves of moria from their
home
and was seen in the fellowship of the
ring as it chased the company and later
battled
to death with gander of the grey number
8
molten man from spider-man far from home
the elementals were a series of
illusions created by the use of
projectors and drones utilized by
mysterio or otherwise known later as
quentin beck
and they were used to wreak havoc across
the world so the molten man is an
elemental with the ability to manipulate
the element of fire depicted as the
strongest and the most dangerous of the
four elementals
molten man has been poised to have been
the one to have killed quentin beck's
family on earth 833
theoretically as per beck's false story
it would feed upon metal to expand
exponentially and would consume land
masses once
it was strong enough but in the movie it
grew to be only around
30 feet tall or 9 meters number 7 the
phoenix force from
x-men dark phoenix a list of the five
entities is incomplete without a phoenix
and in the x-men movies
it comes as the phoenix force which is
one of the most powerful and the oldest
known cosmic entities representing
life that has not been born yet as well
as the forces of creation and
destruction
the phoenix force is an immortal
indestructible and mutable
manifestation of the prime universal
force of life
born of the void between the states of
being the phoenix force
is a child of the universe well the
phoenix force chose to reside within a
powerful mutant psychic called jean grey
but its true form was similar to a fiery
bird that can traverse through
interstellar space
and also through the minds of all life
forms
number six deca from moana tikka is the
main antagonist of the disney film
moana and she was once the benevolent
god defeated
but after her heart was stolen by the
demigod maui
she became a destructive lava demon
taker is
quite literally a heartless and
destructive creature with a fiery
disposition
the theft of her heart has stripped her
off the tafitti's benevolence
replacing it with malice she is massive
in size and we estimate her to be around
100 to 150 feet tall and that's between
30 and 45 meters ticker towers above all
who encounters her and is usually
depicted in a hollow skull
always surrounding her slender form in a
dense pyrocumulus cloud coupled with
balls of lightning and volcanic ash
number five rodan from king of the
monsters this
giant pterodon kaiju was created by toho
that first appeared in one of the first
monster movies
ever in the 1956 toho film of its own
name
rodan but the one we are focusing on
this list is the fire demon from the
monsterverse
this incarnation of rodan has a wingspan
of around 871
feet or 265 meters across and was
154 feet or 47 meters tall
his physique overall bears a strong
resemblance to a bird of prey his skin
is burgundy coloured and possesses a
texture similar to molten rock
with fiery bumps and ridges along his
chest and back
the wing membrane appeared to be lined
with heated glowing crags
making it appear as if rodin's wings are
smoldering with fire and lava
number 4 satan from this is the n
this version of the evil demon is the
main antagonist of the 2013 dark comedy
fantasy film this is the end
satan is dead set on bringing forth
armageddon onto the earth and destroying
all life presumably to
so that he can increase his amount of
doomed souls forced to do his bidding he
unleashed his hellish legions to possess
humans
he takes the appearance of a hoofed
legged humanoid horned demon with
several eel-like heads protruding from
his back
satan is revealed to be kaiju's size
around
to 300-400 feet tall and with a body
comprised of hardened lava and fire
and has a large exposed penis also he
bleeds magma and is burning constantly
number three burning godzilla from king
of the monsters and godzilla vs
destroyer
although he is an aquatic kaiju this
form was a transformation endured by the
king of the monsters
and godzilla was the destoroyah of 1995
as he inadvertently absorbed the energy
from a hidden
uranium deposit that boosted his power
on a massive scale causing him to go
into meltdown
but in 2019 in the king of the monsters
movie this transformation was again
seen when he absorbed the nuclear
explosion that was meant to
revive him coupled with mothra's energy
that was absorbed by him later on
it became a catalyst for his new fiery
and burning form which he uses to kill
ghidorah
and at 400 feet tall or 120 meters tall
he is the third biggest fire monster on
this list
number 2 cronus from the wrath of the
titans
in this movie as in mythology he is the
king of the titans
the father of the gods his physical form
is composed of fire
lava and molten rock lines of lava
surround cronus body
mouth and eyes which would suggest that
the inside parts of his body is also the
same
and is completely composed of lava in
the past the gods needed the aid of the
kraken to defeat cronus and the rest of
the titans as well
although it sounds like an embellishment
as the kraken was around 400 feet tall
but this died in kronos was 500 meters
tall or 1640 feet in height
more than four times taller than the
kraken and number one
serta from thor ragnarok this fire demon
was the ruler of masspelheim and was
prophesied to be the one to start a
world-changing event called ragnarok in
the past certain was successfully
defeated by odin who stole from him the
source of his power
which was the eternal flame as a fire
demon serta can generate massive waves
of fiery energy from his twilight sword
to engulf his targets and flames this
fire was strong enough that in his
weakened state he was able to force thor
using his hammer back and make him
struggle
when released on asgard later on he
started to grow to heights of around 500
meters to one kilometer tall
and with fires that could engulf the
whole of asgard itself it makes him the
biggest fire monster in this list
and so with that we come to the end of
this list so do like share and subscribe
and do check out our merchandise
but most of all do click on that
notification bell for regular updates
as you might have missed a couple of
videos that we have posted recently
take care